it's been kicking around for about five
or ten years and part of what inspired
me was the sense that the medium in
which we swim technologically speaking
is about to change and we can feel hints
of that change coming and so much of it
has been with us for so long that we
don't even notice it's there even though
a lot of what we love about the IT
revolution is premise thanh it there are
a couple key moments I think everybody
can remember one or two internet
phenomena or technological phenomenon
that when they saw demo they were like
wow I want one or this changes
everything and in that sense I remember
the first time I saw TiVo I remember the
first time I saw instant messenger as a
desktop mainstream app rather than as a
UNIX application running on a mainframe
that very few people knew about and each
time I would see a different shoe
dropped with a new application it would
either reinforce in me the sense of wow
you never know what the internet is
going to produce next I remember the
first time I saw Napster in operation
and I had been asked to have a view on
Napster before I actually used it and I
found out how it worked and realized you
could use it to chain exchange files and
music and things like that and thought
you know well on the one hand on the
other hand then I start an operation I
was like this is so illegal there's no
way this thing is legal and so sometimes
you see the new app and you say wow like
what kind of egg is the internet going
to lay next it's just like so
unpredictable and then sometimes you see
a new application or a new technology
and you say wow who knew you could take
something that had been fuzzy or rough
and smooth it over and package it so
brilliantly an apple gives us a lot of
those moments the ipod wear to this day
there are people with regular old mp3
players who are
I don't see the big deal I can spend
half the money and get at least as much
of the functionality but it's not an
ipod and others who say no the ipod is
what introduced those people to music in
a portable way beyond the Walkman and
the iphone and things like that so in my
own head i think i started to see some
tension between the really spiffy
aesthetically pleasing fully functional
but not going to surprise you beyond the
initial novelty appliance on the one
hand and the more geeky boxy
unpredictable chaotic internet and pc on
the other